et nous soit vous en direct par skype
avec un guillaume bigot politologue et
céistes bonjour et merci de prendre le
temps de répondre à nos questions sur
arte france qu'avez vous pensé de cette
longue prise de parole hier à du premier
ministre du ministre de la santé on a
aussi entendu le directeur général de la
santé a dressé le bilan quotidien on du
corps d'un virus à dans l'hexagone à la
fois sur la forme évidemment sur le fond
quel est votre ressenti ce matin alors
sur le fond je suis pas du tout
épidémiologistes ni médecin donc je ne
me prononcerai pas j'ai compris
simplement que virus étaient en
circulation que si les frontières
étaient hermétiquement bouclées dans ce
pays qu'on attendait suffisamment pour
qu'il n'y ait plus de car on avait
peut-être un espoir d'arrêter sa
propagation ce qui posait néanmoins des
tas de questions sur le caractère
évidemment intenable de 7,2 cette
position sur le long terme tant qu'ap
attacks un ehpad de médicaments ce qu'on
a également compris voilà pour le fond
pour le reste sur le fond il n'y a rien
de nouveau donc finalement ce qu'on a ce
qu'on peut conclure c'est que rien
n'avait sautant l'autorité d'un pouvoir
que d'essayer de s'exprimer pour ne pour
ne rien dire le mal je pense avait
commencé avec la location des présidents
républicains qui c'est qui n'a pas
résisté à sa lubie samani c'est à dire
le fameux en même temps donc je donne
une date extrêmement précises de 11 mai
et je déconfit le 11 mai en même temps
dit qu'il faut que les conditions soient
réunies pour des confié le 11 mai donc
si on a bien compris ce sera le gros de
même ce ne sera pas le 11 mai alors bien
sûr que c'est une sorte de grenade que
le prénom de république a dégoupillé une
grenade politique et monsieur gérant est
monsieur philippe ont dû ont été
contraints finalement de jongler avec
cette grenade dégoupillée n'était pas
très ce qui n'est pas très confortable
quand même relativement périlleux et le
résultat qui se voulait clair et
pédagogique est un monde à mon sens mais
j'ai l'impression qu'en regardant les
commentaires aujourd'hui ce matin on a
plutôt cette impression que ça a été
très amphigourique et extrêmement
extrêmement brouillon donc finalement il
ya une première partie dans lequel on
nous a expliqué ils ont tout de suite
botté en touche à ils ont dit mais ne
nous demandez surtout pas comment on va
goûter confiné techniquement le 11 mai
parce que ça on n'a pas
réponse donc été le coeur du sujet
pourtant ensuite ils se sont attachés je
pense que c'était très bien fait et très
clair à de montrer ce qui se serait
passé si on n'avait pas confiné et
résultats du confinement
donc la conclusion logique c'est qu'il
fallait rester confinés et alors là où
le problème s'est posé c'est le malaise
s'est installé s'est tout de suite après
on nous a dit en raison de la récession
extrêmement brutal la pire depuis 1945
et pour empêcher donc je cite le premier
ministre la nation de s'effondrer il va
falloir se dé confiné donc il faut donc
choisir entre la peste du coc vie des
locaux les radars récession donc rester
confiné c'est se suicider ce dès qu'on
finisse et sauter par la fenêtre alors
qu'il n'avait pas rappelé comme le
premier ministre a renvoyé à la
présentation de son plan détaillé dans
quelques semaines ce plan de l'attrait
confinement sera détaillé dans les
quinze jours qui viennent résultat vous
l'avez rappelé pad annonce concrète hier
en revanche une mise en garde
la crise sanitaire se poursuit ce que
c'est là le message politique qu'il faut
retenir d'hier soir oui mais la crise
sanitaire se poursuit s'est expliqué
tous les soirs par cette ce monsieur
c'est le monde mx1 le directeur général
de la santé qui fait office d'une sorte
de notaire de notaire de l'effroi 1 il y
faisait monsieur loyal du coc vite
qu'ils nous expliquent tous les soirs
les dégâts du cockpit où que je sois
tout on a bien compris les gestes
barrières tout on a bien compris la
nécessité de se conformer aux consignes
du confinement et le pays le fait donc
là les messages sont pas sont pas plus
importants que ceux là le message
central s'était effectivement d'abord le
mode d'emploi du déconfinement il ça
c'est dans quinze jours alors ça aurait
pu tenir en deux minutes
rendez-vous dans quinze jours nous n'en
savons pas plus et même ça c'était
relativement trop d'une certaine façon
alors si vous voulez vraiment ça sur la
question très précise du port du masque
et déteste le temps du masque sera
probablement obligatoire dans les
transports publics notamment à partir du
11 mai le gouvernement espère aussi
pouvoir réaliser quelques 500 mille
tests par semaine ce qu'on peut la
parler d'un revirement de la part du
gouvernement sur ces deux points
bah c'est plus qu'un sais plus quel
revirement oui bien sûr
excellent et le test les masques qui
servait à rien pourrait être obligatoire
c'est quand même un désaveu j'ai noté
que le ministre de la santé monsieur
verrons
cette formule il a dit je leur utilité
en parlant des masques je cite je ne la
nie pas et je ne pourrais le faire vous
pouvez le faire s'il était une tentation
de faire mais là c'est plus possible en
fait puisque mais on l'a même vu le
président de la république arborer un
masque donc c'est et puis ça fait partie
des recommandations et puis en effet
pour le rappeler dans les transports en
commun mais bon on n'est plus à une
contradiction près des transports en
commun en région parisienne à lyon et
marseille sont bondés et probablement
partout ailleurs sur le territoire dans
des zones de grande concentration
humaine ou comment prendre les
transports en commun et respecté des
gestes barrières d'un mètre avec des
masques en plus faim tout ça est
complètement fou quand contre le pr
ministre audio les masques pourrait être
obligatoire notamment dans les
transports en commun il faut traduire le
maquereau le maquereau en français c'est
à dire des masques seront obligatoires
en fait un temps il faut préciser en
même temps lorsqu on les aura merci
d'avoir pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions guillaume bigot politologue et
essayiste ça